[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for security
policy will ignoring and denying a
problem make it go away that question
came to mind regarding the controversy
that has erupted over a mosque in New
Hampshire that an investigator contends
is preaching jihad instead of checking
this out however the local police chief
claims that the charges are just
Islamophobia is he really willing to bet
the safety of his local citizens on that
the New Hampshire union-leader broke the
story recently not by reporting on the
investigation of the mosque or even what
was being claimed about it but only
reporting on the reaction from the
mosque leaders and local law enforcement
officials all of whom agreed that the
mosque had been unfairly accused since
the union leader however did not include
the accusations
there was no way really to tell whether
or not this was true then an
investigative journalist James Simpson
published the evidence and made it clear
this mosque very much warrants
investigation and the Manchester New
Hampshire police chief Nick Willard is
derelict in his duty Simpson reports
that investigator Dave gobbets
found a great deal of material promoting
jihad in the mosque including a brochure
entitled jihad in Islam Simpson writes
this thirty three page document makes
clear that the goals of Islam are to
subjugate the world under the heading
what jihad really is it states in
reality Islam is a revolutionary
ideology and program which seeks to
alter the social order of the whole
world and rebuild it in conformity with
its own tenets and ideals muslim is the
title of that international
revolutionary party organized by Islam
to carry into effect its revolutionary
program and jihad refers to that
revolutionary struggle an utmost
exertion which the Islamic party brings
into play to achieve this objective
Islam requires the earth this brochure
adds not just a portion but the whole
planet not because the sovereignty over
the earth should be rest
did from one nation or several nations
and vested in one particular nation but
because the entire mankind should
benefit from the ideology and welfare
program or what would be truer to say
from Islam which is the program of
wellbeing for all humanity towards this
end Islam wishes to press into service
all forces which can bring about a
revolution and a composite term for the
use of all these forces is jihad now
this was found in this mosque and much
more besides the union leader peace does
quote Dave Gavitt saying on a scale of
one to ten with ten being the most
extreme I rate this mosque a ten then it
goes to the chairman of the Islamic
Society of New Hampshire Muhammad Elias
who said these unsubstantiated charges
are full of lies and have spread
distrust of his community and Manchester
New Hampshire police chief Nick Willard
declared that what gobbets had reported
is quote slanderous I do not believe the
mosque is a hotbed for terrorism I don't
trust this gentleman's research I think
he's trying to sell a book I think the
guy is a crackpot and I don't believe we
have those issues in this city
the union leader stated that Willard
said his detective embedded in the FBI
Joint Terrorism Task Force has no
information that corroborates gobbets
his claim Willard doesn't mention and
probably doesn't know that the FBI is
forbidden to study anything involving
Islam in connection with terrorism this
was something mandated by Barack Obama
back in 2011 and so it wouldn't know the
danger signs to look for in a mosque
even if those danger signs stab them
with a machete while screaming Allahu
Akbar Willard offers an argument from
Authority which is the weakest of all
arguments if you've studied logic in
invoking the joint terrorism task force
without establishing that the Joint
Terrorism Task Force is at all competent
in this area he then offered an ad
hominem attack another logical fallacy
on Dave gobbets asserting with no
evidence that gobbets is just trying to
sell a book and is a crackpot this was a
classic example of the
Nonna's shut up he explained and lends
credence to gobbets as claims because
clearly the manchester police department
doesn't even want to consider the
possibility that there may be problems
with this mosque so if there really are
what then Willard was not alone
Manchester aldermen chairman Patrick
long declared personally this hate talk
has no place in this city that's just my
opinion now he wasn't talking about the
material about jihad found in the mosque
he was talking about gobbets for calling
attention to it alderman at-large dan
O'Neill said there is no need in the
City of Manchester for hatred I know
this board won't stand for it
our citizens won't stand for it how the
fools like this get elected long and
oniel ought to be ashamed of themselves
if they still have the capacity for
shame and not to be voted out of office
at the earliest possible opportunity
it is not hatred to raise legitimate
concerns about what is being taught in
mosques as well as the fact that 80
percent of the mosques in the US are
Saudi funded and the reality of Islam's
teachings on jihad the rights of women
Jews and much more all caused concern to
smear gobbets is spreading hate without
any investigation of his specific
assertions about the mosque is to do
what they claim he's doing now Nick
Willard added that gobbets quote Stokes
the flames of fear but he does so
through hatred bigotry and intolerance
his Islamophobia has no place in our
country and certainly no place in the
fine city of Manchester that embraces
diversity of all levels to include
freedom of religion where do they find
these guys the Islamophobia charge is a
propaganda term designed to intimidate
people into fearing to oppose Jihad
terror willard's statement here is a
classic example of how it works
what if Givat says claims about the
mosque or truth and this is the response
he's getting then in the future people
will be afraid to speak up about what
they may see going on in mosques for
fear of incurring charges of hatred and
Islamophobia chief Willard needs to be
put on notice if Givat says charges
indeed do turn out to be true
and you have waved them away by defaming
him then when it becomes clear he was
right the responsibility for the
devastation in your city will be on your
head in a sane City Nick Willard will be
forced to resign and disgrace over this
episode but like so many other cities in
America today Manchester New Hampshire
is not a sane city
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]